just when you think you're out of the
Veronica Mars fandom they pull you back
in buckle up marshmallows because we're
taking a road trip back to Neptune to
investigate a potential season 5 in the
fall of 2018 Hulu announced that it
would air an 8 episode Revival of
Veronica Mars slated for release in 2019
by July of that year fans around the
world were gearing up for a new season
that was years in the making after the
2014 Veronica Mars movie which was
largely regarded as total fan service
audiences were excited to see Veronica
back in episodic format especially since
Creator and showrunner Rob Thomas
promised a grittier reboot that felt
more like the original series that
premiered in 2004 season 4 of Veronica
Mars ended up dropping a week early on
July 19th 2019 after the cast and crew
assembled for a panel at that Year's San
Diego ComicCon of course viewers rushed
to binge the short series and get their
fix as fast as possible both fans and
critics like the season so why has
season 5 never come to pass as Thomas
revealed the TV line in 2019 he has
ideas for more stories in mind but Hulu
made it clear at that time that they had
no interest in further Veronica Mar's
adventures and their opinion doesn't
seem to have changed nowadays Thomas is
busy with the party down reboot and
Bella has been devoting her time to
Productions like Frozen 3 Central Park
and the woman in the house across the
street from the girl in the window they
might still be down to return to Neptune
but if Hulu isn't into it it's unlikely
to happen blows that would destroy most
people she always picks herself back up
most of the Cor cast of Veronica Mars
ended up returning for the season 4
Revival including Kristen Bell Jason
doring enrio colon Percy dags II thiri
Ryan Hansen and Francis cpra the season
also brought in a handful of new faces
like Patton Oswalt Kirby Howell Baptist
and even Academy Award winner JK Simmons
it remains to be seen which members of
the cast would return for a possible
season five but one actor definitely
wouldn't fans were shocked dismayed and
heartbroken when Logan Eckles the love
of Veronica's life was killed by one
last bomb at the end of season 4 ding is
confident that Logan would remain 6 feet
under in any future installments but
noted that it's possible Veronica Mars
could bring new and old faces back to
Neptune again as far as Bella is
concerned she's definitely in for
Veronica Mars season 5 if it happens as
the star remarked at ComiCon I'll play
Veronica until everyone in Neptune is
dead the end of Veronica Mars season 4
sees Veronica hit the highest highs and
lowest lows of her life thus far after
marrying her longtime Lov Logan and
committing to the relationship once and
for all she ends up watching as Logan
Falls victim to a Car Bomb meant for her
hidden as one last gift from pen Epler
The Season's villain one year later
Veronica is finally seeking therapy
which was a huge bone of contention
between Veronica and Logan while he was
alive and leaving Neptune seemingly for
good taking to the road to pick up more
cases for Mars investigations this
ending definitely opens the door for
plenty more Mysteries and season 5 could
possibly focus on Veronica's post
Neptune career as well as the going on
at Mars investigations back in
California regarding the latter setting
Keith has taken a new Veronica es protoe
named MD under his wing her father was
killed in the first spring break bombing
I guess I just want to go into this with
my eyes wide open were Veronica Mars to
earn a season 5 it would have to find a
way to handle the elephant in the room
Logan's sudden shocking death by carbomb
why did he have to go in such brutal
tragic fashion according to Rob Thomas
it was necessary he told ET it's like
cutting off a limb to save the body
veroda Mars had no future with him and
toe my feeling is that if we move
forward it has to move forward as a Noir
detective show and it's hard to do that
when your Kick-Ass Noir detective as a
boyfriend back home it becomes
increasingly difficult to work many fans
were outraged by the loss but Thomas has
no regrets when TV line asked him if
he'd reconsidered the decision his
answer was Swift and assured no not even
a little bit I know what the show needs
to be moving forward there is a reason
shows end when the couple gets together
I'm not going to start doing the Thin
Man it's not going to be Veronica and
Logan solving iies so what is Logan
doing in the show he knew fans would be
upset and even accepted their ey as
valid saying that he won't begrudge them
if they aren't willing to watch a
Veronica Mars without
Logan